LeBron James this first shot of the  night game side scoop layup and a foul  George on the perimeter five to shoot  James won't go Kevin Love the rebound  throws it down to James catches and  traffic impacts at all  doesn't get things going James throws it  up misses rebound rights back to looking  to come help doesn't want to leave  Thompson alone and James knocks down the  shins goes Adam pulls back it's in the  paint one-handed shot bounces around  James pulls back puts it up putts it  here's James powers to the basket bank  shot is good he got the to lose to way  guys and they get there and they got  fortunate James becomes James down lamps  good inside banks at home games behind  the back throws it up pass deflected  stolen back by Jared city banks at home